[Music]  Kanye West celebrates his birthday with  the mind-blowing soiree the rapper  turned 41 on Friday and celebrated with  an epic party on Saturday night which  wife Kim Kardashian documented on  Instagram stories  Kanye's sister-in-laws kendall Jenner  and Kourtney Kardashian were on the  guest list  Israeli Mentalist Li or su chard was  also in attendance to try and  entertained guests with the night of  magical performances to top it all off  party goers were served cookies and  beverages featuring Kanye face and of  course what celebration is complete  without cake but that wasn't Kanye's  only birthday fun on Friday Kim tweeted  this Rick and Morty audio birthday card  she had commissioned for her rapper  hubby got a place to be right now  Kanye's birthday party of course Kanye  is a huge fan in May he took to Twitter  to celebrate the show getting renewed  for 70 more episodes  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]